Visitors to the Saratoga National Historical
Park in New York may see the Boot Monument,
a frieze that commemorates the Battle of Saratoga,
one of the most significant wins for the Americans
over the British during the Revolutionary
War.
Specifically, it honors one officer described
as the “most brilliant soldier of the Continental
Army”.
And although it is extremely bizarre, it does
not show his likeness or even name the officer
in question.
Image: Boot Monument
There is a reason for that.
The monument is dedicated to Benedict Arnold,
a man presented in history classes around
the United States as the most notorious traitor
in the country’s history.
There is no better exemplification of the
conundrum posed by Arnold than the Boot Monument.
Before he betrayed his country, he had several
victories that were instrumental to the overall
success of the Continental Army.
However, constant arguments with his peers
and being the target of numerous slights and
insults, both real and perceived, eventually
persuaded him to switch sides and attempt
to surrender West Point to the British.
That’s how we ended up with strange things
like a memorial that does not name its honoree.
People wanted to praise Arnold’s early career
but, at the same time, the mere mention of
his name revulsed many Americans.
And no, in case you were wondering, the monument
was not erected before Arnold’s betrayal.
In fact, it was built over a hundred years
later, at the behest of John Watts de Peyster,
himself a Major General during the Civil War.
There is a certain “Jekyll and Hyde” element
to Arnold’s legacy and today we are going
to try to unravel, as best we can, the tale
of the unnamed hero and the despicable villain
that was Benedict Arnold.
Early Life and Education
Benedict Arnold was born on January 14, 1741,
in Norwich, then a part of the Colony of Connecticut.
The second of six children, his parents were
Benedict Arnold Sr. and Hannah Waterman King.
In fact, the younger Arnold was the fourth
Benedict in his family, all named after his
great-grandfather who served as the Governor
of the Colony of Rhode Island and Providence
Plantations.
On his mother’s side, Arnold was descended
from Reverend John Lothropp (sometimes Lathrop),
an influential New England clergyman who helped
settle the city of Barnstable, Massachusetts,
and was one of the first people in the colonies
to champion the idea of separation of church
and state.
At first, it seemed like Arnold would have
an easy ride through life.
He was born into a wealthy family and his
father was a successful businessman.
He went to private school in Canterbury, Connecticut,
and was expected to continue his studies at
a prestigious university, most likely Yale.
However, when he was a teenager, three of
his siblings died of Yellow Fever.
His father did not take their losses well
and started drinking heavily.
In turn, this led to multiple failed business
deals until, eventually, he lost the family
company.
With the money gone, the Arnolds had no choice
but to pull young Benedict from school and
find him work.
His mother appealed to two of her cousins,
Daniel and Joshua Lathrop, to take him on
as an apprentice to their expanding apothecary
business so he could learn the trade.
She died a few years later, in 1759, followed
by her husband two years after that.
Arnold proved to be an adept merchant.
Once his apprenticeship was finished, he borrowed
money from his uncles and traveled to Europe
to secure goods.
He opened his own apothecary in New Haven
which proved to be successful.
In just a few years, he managed to settle
all his family debts.
He also married Margaret Mansfield in 1767
and had three children together before her
death in 1775.
Early Military Career
Arnold’s military career kicked off almost
two decades before the Revolutionary War.
As a youth, he wanted to fight in the French
and Indian War against his mother’s wishes.
Eventually, he managed to join a Connecticut
militia but, as far as we can tell, never
actually saw combat.
As a successful businessman, Arnold felt the
oppressive boot of the British government
more and more.
The Sugar and Stamp Acts were passed in 1764
and 1765, respectively, to tax the North American
colonies.
This was an attempt to increase revenue by
a government that was hurting financially
following the Seven Years’ War, but, unsurprisingly,
proved to be wildly unpopular in North America.
Response to the new taxes was almost universally
negative, but to varying degrees.
Some tried to take the legal route and argued
that it was unconstitutional for the government
to levy direct taxes since only their representative
assemblies could do this.
“No taxation without representation” became
their rallying slogan.
Others resorted to mob violence to deter collectors
from doing their jobs.
Meanwhile, Benedict Arnold and many like him
simply continued to operate normally, in defiance
of the British Government which, technically,
turned him into a smuggler.
He also joined the Sons of Liberty, a secret
organization that sought to protect the interests
of colonists against the British Crown.
Outbreak of the War
Arnold’s first position during the Revolutionary
War was as a captain with a New Haven militia
called the Second Company of Governor’s
Foot Guard.
When the Battles at Lexington and Concord
signaled the start of the conflict, his men
were ready to march.
Well...maybe not so fast.
The militia was ready to go, but the New Haven
town council led by David Wooster had a meeting
and decided that they should wait for regular
orders.
Consequently, they refused to release any
gunpowder to the soldiers.
Back then, because gunpowder was so volatile
and dangerous, a town’s entire supply was
generally kept in one safe place - usually,
a magazine or a church basement - and the
keys were safeguarded carefully.
Frustrated by the denial, Arnold confronted
Wooster in a tavern and demanded the keys,
saying that he intended to march even if he
had to break into the powder house.
The town council relented and, after arming
themselves, the militia trooped to Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Image suggestion: Powder House Day celebration
This little moment of glory for Benedict Arnold
is well-remembered in New Haven.
Since 1904, the city commemorates it every
year on April 22 as Powder House Day.
On the Way to Fort Ticonderoga
Arnold’s militia was on its way to take
part in the Siege of Boston, but on the way
met Colonel Samuel Holden Parsons.
The two of them discussed the Continental
Army’s desperate need for artillery and
brought up the fact that Fort Ticonderoga
on Lake Champlain had plenty of cannons guarded
only by a small force.
They agreed that the fort would be a great
asset to them so, while Parsons continued
his journey, Arnold went to Cambridge where
he persuaded the Massachusetts Committee of
Safety to fund his expedition to capture the
fort.
Image: Ethan Allen
Now we arrive at the first instance where
Arnold felt slighted by his own side.
He was not the only one planning to attack
Fort Ticonderoga.
A second militia from the New Hampshire Grants
called the Green Mountain Boys were also on
route.
They were led by Ethan Allen, a man who would
go on to be one of the founders of Vermont.
Arnold and Allen did not get along and this
was the first in a series of rivalries that
Benedict would have with fellow officers.
Whether or not he was justified in his enmity,
we cannot really say with certainty since
both sides gave their own versions of the
story.
Benedict Arnold had been made a colonel and
had official orders to lead the charge on
Fort Ticonderoga.
This did not mean anything to Allen who refused
to relinquish command nor to his Green Mountain
Boys who would not obey the orders of any
other officer.
They knew they had all the leverage because
they accounted for the bulk of the military
force.
Eventually, Arnold had no choice but to concede
and accept Ethan Allen as the co-leader of
the expedition.
Some historians see it as even more insulting
to Arnold.
They argue that he was only allowed to ride
at the front of the military column alongside
Allen for pure symbolism and had no actual
authority.
We should mention that there was also a third,
smaller force led by one Colonel James Easton
who got along even worse with Arnold and their
relationship eventually descended into violence.
According to Arnold’s journal, he took the
liberty of “breaking his head” and then
challenging Easton to a duel.
When the latter refused to relinquish his
other weapons and “draw like a gentleman”,
Arnold kicked him “very heartily” and
told him to leave
the point.
Taking the
Fort
Despite the animosity between Arnold and his
fellow officers, the attack on Fort Ticonderoga
was an unmitigated success.
During the early hours of May 10, 1775, around
80 soldiers crossed Lake Champlain undetected
and snuck into the fort, taking the British
garrison by surprise.
The militia managed to capture the citadel
without any fatalities.
From there, the men also took the nearby Fort
George and Fort Crown Point which had even
fewer soldiers guarding them.
This victory was cause for celebration.
According to Arnold’s journal, the Green
Mountain Boys broke into the rum supply and
drank themselves into a stupor.
Meanwhile, his own captains started to show
up with additional men.
Now that he had a sizable force on his side,
Arnold sought to claim some glory for himself.
His target was Fort Saint-Jean on the Canadian
side of Lake Champlain.
Like the other fortresses, it was poorly guarded,
but it also had the HMS Royal George, the
only major warship in those waters.
It would have been a fitting prize for the
ambitious officer who knew that Ethan Allen
would try to claim as much credit as possible
for the capture of Fort Ticonderoga.
Indeed, when he wrote his memoir, Allen neglected
to mention Benedict Arnold by name.
A week after taking Ticonderoga, Arnold’s
men rowed in small boats called bateaux and
reached Fort Saint-Jean undetected.
The element of surprise was enough to overpower
the small garrison, but Arnold found out that
a large British force was on its way from
Montreal.
The capture of the fort turned into a raid.
Arnold and his men took all the supplies they
could aboard the Royal George and sunk everything
else.
Image: USS Enterprise
Arnold decided to rechristen the warship as
the USS Enterprise.
It became the first in a long line of prestigious
American ships that carried that name - a
tradition which, if Star Trek is to be believed,
will continue hundreds of years into the future.
Ethan Allen and his men started to disperse
from Fort Ticonderoga and Arnold assumed that
he would take command.
Instead, Colonel Benjamin Hinman arrived with
a large force of 1,000 soldiers and orders
from Connecticut Governor Jonathan Trumbull
which said that Arnold would serve as his
subordinate.
Incensed by another perceived injustice, Arnold
resigned his commission and headed home.
On the way, he learned that his wife had passed
away and, shortly after, Arnold himself was
struck by gout, a painful disease which would
plague him for the rest of his life.
Disaster in Canada
Despite these setbacks, Arnold was not quite
ready to give up on the military life just
yet.
Among others, he was of the opinion that the
Continental Army’s next move should be to
invade Quebec via their newly-gained foothold
on Lake Champlain.
This would deny the British a solid base of
operations should they want to charge into
New York.
Again, Arnold was refused the opportunity
to lead the expedition, with that honor going
to Major General Philip Schuyler.
He turned out to be quite a rarity in that
he was a Continental officer that Benedict
Arnold actually got along with.
However, he was stricken by illness and was
forced to relinquish command to Brigadier
General Richard Montgomery.
Image: Richard Montgomery
Arnold convinced his superiors that a two-pronged
attack would work better.
He was given 1,100 men and a colonel’s commission
by George Washington himself and told to meet
up with Montgomery’s forces and take Quebec
City.
There was just one problem.
In order for this assault to work, Arnold
had to take his troops through the harsh wilderness
of Maine and Quebec, over rough terrain, in
cold September weather.
Almost half of his soldiers died or deserted
before they reached their goal.
Meanwhile, the British got wind of this planned
attack and shored up their defenses.
The six hundred or so soldiers who remained
joined up with an equal force commanded by
General Montgomery and, on December 31, 1775,
attacked Quebec City.
The battle was a disaster for the continental
forces.
Montgomery died leading the assault.
Most of his soldiers were killed, injured,
or taken prisoner.
The remaining forces fell under the command
of Benedict Arnold who sustained a leg injury
during the fight.
Instead of retreating, Arnold decided to maintain
a siege on the city in the hopes that reinforcements
would come.
New units did arrive, commanded by David Wooster,
the same man who didn’t want to supply Arnold’s
militia with gunpowder.
He was now a major general and took control
of the siege while Arnold traveled to Montreal.
As a consolation prize, he found out that
he had been promoted to brigadier general
for his efforts.
Legal Troubles
Continental forces gave up on Quebec City
once British reinforcements were on the way
and it became clear that there was no salvaging
that disastrous mission.
Unsurprisingly, the enemy pressed their advantage
and continued on to Montreal to gain back
the territory they had lost in Canada.
Arnold spent the rest of the year in Quebec,
trying to slow down the advance of the British
as much as possible.
He distinguished himself in two conflicts:
the Battle of the Cedars and the Battle of
Valcour Island.
However, because it had been a while since
he had an argument with another officer, Arnold
brought charges of dereliction of duty against
General Moses Hazen.
He claimed that the latter refused to take
goods from Montreal merchants and send them
to supply Arnold’s garrison.
This led to a court-martial for Hazen, but
his rank, his service, and his connections
ensured that he got off.
In turn, he pressed counter charges against
Arnold and had him court-martialed.
Moreover, he was joined by two junior officers
who had their own issues with Arnold, John
Brown and the aforementioned James Easton.
Unlike Hazen, Arnold was never honorably acquitted
of the accusations against him.
Instead, General Horatio Gates intervened
and dissolved the arrest warrant, believing
that the brigadier general was too valuable
in battle to lose over legal matters.
It certainly sounds like Gates was on the
same page as Arnold, but stick around because
that will not last long.
Meanwhile, in a rather prophetic move, John
Brown was not content with the ruling in Arnold’s
favor.
He wanted the world to know what kind of man
the general was and distributed a pamphlet
where he wrote of Benedict Arnold that “money
is this man’s God, and to get enough of
it he would sacrifice his country”.
Success at Saratoga
We are approaching the crowning achievement
of Benedict Arnold’s military career - his
service during the Battles of Saratoga.
However, it almost never happened because,
once again, he wanted to resign his position.
Arnold was angered by the fact that several
junior officers, some of them his enemies,
were promoted to major general ahead of him.
It was only due to George Washington’s direct
interference that he decided to postpone his
resignation and, instead, serve under General
Schuyler at Saratoga.
Eventually, Continental Congress promoted
Arnold to major general, but refused to reinstate
his seniority, meaning that those junior officers
still remained his superiors.
At Saratoga, Arnold found out not only of
Congress’ refusal to restore his seniority,
but also that Schuyler had been replaced with
General Horatio Gates.
The general might have defended Arnold during
his court-martial, but their relationship
soured quickly on the battlefield as they
had opposing views on how to approach the
military campaign.
The first engagement occurred on September
19 against British forces led by General John
Burgoyne.
Dubbed the Battle of Freeman’s Farm, it
was a pyrrhic victory for the British.
They might have won the field, but they suffered
greater casualties and failed to weaken the
American position.
Image: John Burgoyne
Most of the success was due to Arnold who
wanted to be aggressive and took his regiments
to meet the British head-on.
However, he felt that he didn’t receive
proper credit in the reports written by Gates’s
party and began butting heads with the superior
officer.
One shouting match got so heated that Gates
relieved Arnold of command although, for an
unclear reason, the latter remained in camp.
This proved instrumental in the second clash
at Saratoga known as the Battle of Bemis Heights.
According to the conventional story, Arnold
ignored Gates’s orders and charged into
battle at a critical point, rallied the men
and captured a British redoubt.
It was also at this point that Arnold was
first shot in the leg and then had it crushed
by his horse falling on it.
A newly-discovered letter suggests that Arnold
had his superior’s permission to engage,
but this is besides the point.
What matters is that Benedict Arnold ensured
a victory for the Continental Army that played
a pivotal role in the outcome of the Revolutionary
War.
A few days later, General Burgoyne surrendered
and this was the move that convinced France
to enter the war as an ally against the British.
In Charge of Philadelphia
Following the Battles of Saratoga, Arnold
took time off active duty to heal his injuries.
In June 1778, after the British withdrew from
Philadelphia, Washington placed him in command
of the city.
Image: Peggy Shippen
His new position provided Arnold ample opportunity
to enrich himself through various shady business
deals and questionable schemes.
This increase in status allowed the major
general to meet the Shippens, one of the wealthiest,
most influential families in Philadelphia.
He fell in love with 18-year-old Peggy Shippen
and the two married in April, 1779.
It’s important to remember that, at this
point in time, there were still people in
the colonies who sympathized with the British
government.
The Shippens were among them.
Now, it’s impossible to say with certainty
how influential Peggy was in getting her husband
to switch sides, but she definitely exposed
him to a new circle of individuals who shared
her views.
Crucially, among them was British spy chief
Major John André.
In fact, historians believe that the two of
them had a romantic tryst before Peggy married
Arnold.
Image: John Andre
Around the same time, the general had been
court-martialed for abusing his power in Philadelphia.
He was found guilty on two charges of using
government transport for personal use and
issuing a pass for a ship he had a financial
stake in.
Arnold received a public chastising from George
Washington who wrote that his sense of duty
compelled him to decry the general’s actions
as “imprudent and improper”.
Whether this was the straw that broke the
camel’s back or he had already made up his
mind by this point, we don’t know.
But Arnold had decided to betray his country.
Betrayal at West Point
Major André acted as a middle-man between
Benedict Arnold and Henry Clinton, the British
Commander-in-Chief in North America.
The offer was £20,000 and a general’s commission.
In return, Arnold would surrender West Point,
a military post on the Hudson River with significant
strategic value.
Image: West Point
On August 3, 1780, Arnold assumed command
and began weakening the post’s defenses
by delaying repairs, draining supplies, and
reassigning troops.
Communication was slow and dangerous between
him and the British so it wasn’t until late
September that he met André again.
The plot was exposed on September 23 when
the spy was caught by militiamen who found
incriminating papers on him that detailed
the entire plan.
André was taken into custody, but Arnold
found out of his arrest in time to flee to
British-controlled New York City aboard the
HMS Vulture.
Peggy managed to join him and the family moved
to London following the end of the war.
Major André was hanged as a spy.
General Explains His Actions
In early October, Arnold published an open
letter titled “To the Inhabitants of America”
to explain why he did it.
Unsurprisingly, it wasn’t because of his
constant fights with other officers, or his
illicit dealings, or his wife’s persuasions.
It was because of the tyranny and corruption
of Congress and the leaders of the Continental
Army.
Arnold argued that once the British government
sorted out the grievances of Americans, there
was no reason why the colonies should not
return to the British Empire.
He also objected to America’s alliance with
Catholic France.
As you might expect, public reception to the
letter was “unfavorable”, to say the least.
Even though the treasonous plot failed, Arnold
was still rewarded handsomely by the British
Crown.
He was granted pay, pensions for his whole
family, and a commission as brigadier general.
However, he never distinguished himself in
battle for the remainder of the war.
Arnold’s life after his betrayal was, fittingly,
bereft of any triumphs.
He made several bad business deals in London
and Saint John, New Brunswick, and had to
deal with multiple lawsuits.
His propensity to anger his peers continued
on the other side of the pond and, in 1792,
Arnold fought a bloodless duel with James
Maitland, the Earl of Lauderdale.
His gout had gotten worse and affected his
good leg.
Eventually, he died in a state of delirium
in 1801, aged 60, leaving behind an indebted
estate.
In the centuries that followed, “Benedict
Arnold” became synonymous with “traitor”
in the United States, with very few people
remembering (or caring, for that matter) about
his service in the war prior to his betrayal.
The only people still troubled by Arnold are
historians who still struggle, to this day,
to find the most accurate perspective to look
at one of the country’s most controversial
figures.